Hello psyched to go errs
We just want to take the time to thank you for all your kind support. We are a team of dedicated
Passionate and hardworking individuals who come together every day with one goal in mind
We want to make psychology come alive for you
We are self-funded and recently launched our patreon if you enjoyed the work we do and find it meaningful
Please stick around until the end of the video for more information
On how to get more involved with us and all the cool rewards you can get from us. We hope you enjoy this video
Sweaty palms nail biting and pacing back and forth in your room are all habits
You're probably already familiar with when you have anxiety
But our bodies also have a surprising way of doing strange things when we worry
Sometimes the unconventional route is also an uncomfortable one here are six weird things
Anxiety causes you to do number one
you have ice cold hands and feet and Marie Alfano an
associate professor of medical psychology at Columbia University Medical Center
States when you're anxious your blood flow is redirected away from your extremities and towards your larger organs in your torso
This is why it makes it hard for your blood to circulate
Well that keeps your hands and feet warm when you feel as though you might be in danger your body enters the fight-or-flight
Mode to prepare yourself to survive
Unfortunately anxiety isn't rational and causes you to feel this
Number two you experience gas problems and frequent urination
Sounds embarrassing
right
But this is unfortunately true being anxious causes you to have an overactive gut
Albano states gas is created when the acid in your stomach is churning while nervousness runs throughout your body when you're anxious
You may also be prone to eating and drinking too quickly
Frequent urination is commonly experienced too when you're anxious
Your muscles tense up and your body puts pressure on areas such as your bladder and abdomen that makes you one of urine able
Although these experiences sound uncomfortable. They're nothing to be ashamed of if you're concerned
You can talk to your doctor about solutions to these symptoms
We hope that by talking about anxiety people can be more accepting of it
Please be sure to also check out our video thirteen things people don't realize you do because of your anxiety
to stay educated on the matter number three
You catch yourself yawning a lot albano states some individuals
Especially with generalized anxiety or pets tend to breathe more rapidly than the average person as a result
Rapid breathing tricks the brain into thinking you need more oxygen, which causes you to take deep
Inhales. So the next time someone thinks you're yawning because you're bored or tired
Inform them that it could be anxiety
Number four you get rashes on your skin?
Anxiety can give you an uncomfortable pitch
metaphorically and
physically albano states that being anxious can frequently cause you to experience
Skin allergies and problems such as eczema. That's because when people find themselves highly stressed
Extra cortisol, which is the stress hormone
Rushes through the bloodstream as a result the skin starts to feel
Irritated and rashes begin to develop if you experience this issue often
We advise you to talk to your doctor about ways to alleviate it
Number five you often space out and have trouble concentrating
Entering a dream light state sounds relaxing and even ideal for escaping your troubles
but having severe anxiety can cause you to have
Out-of-body experiences when things start to feel too overwhelming. You may find that everything around you feels unreal
Including the body that you're in this is because of the fight-or-flight
Mode you enter which prepares you to deal with the current issue by eliminating stimuli nearby. That's too much for you to handle
number six you hear phantom rings and you have anxiety you may constantly be sitting on edge and
Anticipating something one of those events may be a phone call or text message from somebody
You've been waiting to hear back from as a result. You may hear your phone ring or buds
only to check it and find the sound was all in your teeth researchers call this phenomenon ring, xiety or
Phantom ringing for instance people in a relationship with high anxiety may also develop a strong attachment to the partner
So if they're worried their partner isn't as committed
They may expect the worst and think they're talking to someone else to reduce phantom ringing
It's important to talk about the anxieties you have with your partner. It may also be wise to
Disconnect for a while and embrace nature instead does anxiety cause you to do these strange things
Please share your thoughts with us below
Also, don't forget to subscribe for more content from Psych to go and check out our patreon
we started it because we want to grow into a bigger platform that reaches more people who are in need of help with your
contribution
You can receive our psi pendant t-shirt issues of our magazine and many more
Membership benefits your funding will help us produce quality script writing
voiceovers and animation that makes our content both entertaining and
Educational we want to make sure our community members get the best and only the best. Thanks for watching
original article
HTTP psyched to go net forward slash six weird things anxiety causes you to do
Hey everybody
I just want to give a personal thank you video for you guys for always supporting site to go and making this all possible for
Us our vision is to make psychology as accessible as possible so that it promotes self-awareness and it helps you guys grow
however
We want to make more content for you guys and would love your support in buying one of these bracelets from our partner
Intergroup Alice check out the bracelet. It's pretty cool
And it even includes Pluto the link to purchase will all be in the description
Below, and I hope you guys have an amazing day. Bye
You